bonjour québec à des rails merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
alors dire est qu'on peut parler de
faillite des occidentaux en afghanistan
et si oui est ce que l était prévisible
des occidentaux peut être des américains
certainement il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
il a la foi dans la politique menée
depuis vingt ans en afghanistan et dans
une intervention militaire puis dans la
préparation du retrait militaire
américain
les états unis ont échoué
et cette faillite va probablement
coûter cher politiquement au président
bart hayden parce qu'il sent qu aux
etats unis les républicains
n'accepte pas que le pays soit ainsi
humilié et que cela envoie à des heures
sombres de l'histoire américaine
notamment à propos de la défaite et de
la fin de la guerre au vietnam vous
parlez des chacun américain en
afghanistan selon vous qu'est ce qui
explique cet échec
je crois qu'il a la folie très mauvaise
connaissance mais également une
stratégie qui n'était pas conforme à ce
que à l'époque george bush avait appelé
la guerre contre le terrorisme
on sait aujourd'hui mais on savait déjà
lors de l'intervention américaine que
les talibans n'avait pas de
responsabilité directe dans les ans les
attentats contre new york et washington
le 11 septembre 2001 donc c'était une
intervention qui de toutes les manières
politiquement ne pouvait pas t'avoir de
soutien et que par ailleurs les
américains ont aussi échoué à faire la
preuve la démonstration que par une
intervention militaire étrangère
extérieur
instaurer la démocratie
on voit qu'il n'en est rien donc c'est
un déchet à la foire de projets mais
c'est également un mais chez dans la
perspective diplomatique qui est celle
des états unis alors aiea tournant déjà
hier avant même l'entrée des talibans
dans kaboul puisque ashraf ghani le
président afghan a décidé de quitter
l'afghanistan
pourquoi ce choix de la part du
président afghan
ça ne me fait malheureusement c'est un
peu triste pour les revendre et c'est
que c'est pas le moment où le pays est
dans la difficulté et qu'il s'apprête à
tomber entre les mains de leurs ennemis
de leurs adversaires que le capitaine
quitte le bateau au contraire doit
rester à la barre pour tenter de
maintenir une orientation et une
légitimité aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le
cas un peu ce qui se produit d'ailleurs
dans la plupart des capitales régionales
de l'afghanistan qui sont tombées l'une
après l'autre quasiment sans coup férir
et sans combat donc il y à un véritable
problème peut-être de conscience
nationale pour les afghans ce qui
pourrait éventuellement à l'avenir leur
éviter les interventions militaires l
immixtion étrangère
je crois cette conscience nationale
aujourd'hui et peut-être à construire ou
bien à reconstruire ce qu'il me faut
considère qu'elle préexistait à cette
nouvelle prise de contrôle par les
talibans alors maintenant les talibans
sont
tout pouvoir quelle va être leur
stratégie dans les jours dans les
semaines dans les mois à venir
difficile à dire parce que c'est vrai
que les rapports de force ont
considérablement évolué en vingt ans on
voit aussi que
la la fin de l'ère des républicains et
des néoconservateurs ceux qui ont
précisément conduit les états unis dans
l'impasse diplomatique dans laquelle se
trouve en déclarant cette guerre contre
le terrorisme
aujourd'hui
prévost peut être plus les intérêts
économiques à court et à moyen terme
davantage que des intérêts stratégiques
qui pourra mettre d'avoir une vision sur
le long terme alors on voit les uns
après les autres notamment la chine ou
la russie qui expriment ou qui s'exprime
en disant non pas lent bienveillant ni
même leur soutien aux talibans mais qui
tiennent compte de l'évolution des
rapports de porc aujourd'hui ce sont des
talibans qui ont quelques jours ont
repris le contrôle de l'ensemble de
l'afghanistan sans quasiment combat donc
ça c'est un élément qui est extrêmement
important mais pour les talibans eux
mêmes d'ailleurs il faut qu'ils tiennent
compte du fait que si ils ont des
soutiens notamment on peut imaginer que
apprend que le pakistan continuera de
les soutenir ils doivent également
changé de stratégie pour justifier
envers la population que la crise de
contrôle et les paroles rassurantes
qu'ils ont depuis
48 heures ont maintenant sont justifiées
et qu'elle pourrait leur permettre de
s'installer avec une relative
légitimité populaire merci beaucoup
kader abderrahim d'avoir été avec nous
cet après midi je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe merci
beaucoup